pues en españa hay unos 313 mil
colombianos registrados pero solo están
habilitados para votar unos 169 mil 500
que lo han podido hacer desde el lunes
13 de junio hasta hoy domingo 19 de
junio en varios centros habilitados en
17 ciudades del país estos centros han
estado abiertos como lo estarán en
colombia desde las 8 de la mañana hasta
las 4 de la tarde y la situación en este
pabellón de convenciones de la casa de
campo de la ciudad de madrid' donde me
encuentro es de bastante ambiente de
bastantes personas que están viniendo a
ejercer su derecho a voto y en un
constante goteo de personas que se hacen
fotos con la bandera colombiana con que
portan la camiseta de la selección de
colombia entre las opiniones que he
podido recabar hablando con varios de
los colombianos que estaban aquí
ejerciendo su derecho a voto la opinión
principal es la misma quieren cambio
quieren un gobierno que respete los
derechos humanos que escuche a los
colombianos
que no sea corrupto el 100 por ciento de
los 15 o 20 personas con las que he
hablado dijeron que votaron por petro al
que calificaban como la única opción
viable y estas opiniones reflejan
bastante bien los resultados que hubo en
españa en primera vuelta del 29 de mayo
donde el 47 por ciento de los votos se
los llevó gustavo petro frente al 27% de
federico gutiérrez y rodolfo hernández
el contrincante de petro en esta segunda
vuelta se llevó tan solo el
16,2 por ciento de los votos hay que
recordar que colombia es la comunidad
latinoamericana más numerosa aquí en
españa